welcome to this video playing Hanson SS
from from Norway let's see a king send
you a groom fault without ya I can't
resist this weird line with h 40 h 5
interesting yeah maybe maybe this is now
a bit stronger and some as 94 it's not
attacking a real innovation ok he just
took on c4 yeah g4s slightly weakened of
course still it looks like white has a
good a good central control hmm 985
night ha7 huh yeah thus penis is a bit
of a bit of a problem and tease maybe
playing c5 quickly maybe maybe this is
an idea it's it's very cool Queen g6 but
yeah it it's still oh where this is
surprising really wow yeah well this
must be good for white
night coming to f6 this is this is very
dangerous okay Queen f3 right yeah cover
f4 and
hmm
yeah it's got this Queen a5 check so
yeah well that this is just just just
good for what is there something better
can also just take it on c5 what exactly
is is flex point yeah like and I can
just take it okay let's see look d1
he'll take on a2 b3 is probably playing
Queen to deform
yeah come on keep it simple I can I get
just Oh interesting
yeah I don't really mind an endgame
check I'm a born up and i have not
possible yet 96 yeah what is what is
just flat-out winning I think it played
this opening stage I'm far too far too
quickly I mean black was really it was
dangerous and I think he should have
invested a bit of time to make sure he
gets a gets a playbook position um yeah
I can take it I can't take it
let's see how to how to proceed I want
to prevent hook to be five this is just
controlling the position nicely if this
after this look exchange I have 96 to be
five Roxy for wasn't really necessary to
be honest okay but I'm threatening I'm
threatening this now anyway I was after
rook takes ed I'm losing a temple but
this I can just play and then I'd be
five
um
interesting okay might be seven still oh
yeah rook takes rook see one oops check
check
he's almost in a meeting Nettie c7 check
yeah king of eight is allowing and made
so he needs to go to f8 to give me the
f7 point and the next move is a five
check after which a orgy porn will be
decisive
yeah takes g6 takes e6 it's a nice
symmetrical motif check
I think the time are needed i give to
check here this was far easier check
strange strange sometimes check check
check check check check check late yeah
yeah he got into big trouble right off
the opening right out of the opening
Gavin not sure if maybe that's really
some theoretical knowledge now about
this but h5 I don't like so much really
also I can get back to this position
besides Bishop g5 the exchange here not
sure who's favored by H for Jay at age
five well this is this is a bit of an
annoyance but h5 also weakens the
kingside not not sure well but I like
this move really it's it's a bit it's
it's very direct threatening to to win
material and term
if you need some to play McFly c6 this
is a success I don't I don't really know
if this is great this feels like white
should be ok I think so of course he can
can play other other things but what he
did I think it's definitely good for
white this this should be really good
for white if this this is a big threat
yup like has no counter play he tried
for counter play with see high but I can
I can really just just take it Garin
chattin end game is just was very very
nice for four wide of the slim here you
could even debate if maybe not taking us
better but oh this was really a mistake
I should okay it's clear that i can play
move like that black is not really doing
much this is completely completely bad
yeah night p 7 has a big drawback which
I didn't see he could set of this you
could play the spell check and no this
one yeah this is some counter play very
complicated stuff something like this
you threatening further checks this for
example is not working
hmm and then the night takes be said
really wasn't mistaken oh now now
everything's back to back to normal too
yeah round here why this white is just
just winning but you could have played
this check it would have been much much
tougher them to play alright thanks for
watching